الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت
الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله استقيم اعتدلوا استو سو الصف سد
الخلل
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الص راط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ويسالونك عن ذي القرنين قل ساتلو
عليكم منه ذكرا انا مكنا له في الارض
واتيناه من كل شيء
سببا فاتبع
سببا حتى اذا بلغ مغرب الشمس وجدها تغرب
في عين حمئه ووجد
عندها
قوما قلنا يا ذا القرنين اما ان تعذب واما
ان تتخذ فيهم
حسنا قال اما من ظلم فسوف
نعذبه ثم يرد الى ربه
فيعذبه عذابا
نكرا واما من امن وعمل صالحا فله
جزاء
الحسنى وسنقول له من امر نا يسرا ثم اتبع
سببا حتى اذا بلغ مطلع الشمس وجدها تطلع
على قوم لم نجعل لهم من دونها
سترا كذلك وقد احطنا بما لديه خبرا ثم
اتبع
سببا حتى اذا بلغ بين السد دين وجد من
دونهما
قوما وجد من دونهما قوما لا يكادون يفقهون
قولا قالوا يا ذا القرنين ان ياجوج وماجوج
مفسدون في
الارض فهل نجعل لك خرجا على ان تجعل بيننا
وبين هم سدا قال ما مكني فيه ربي خير
فاعينوني
بقوه اجعل بينكم وبينهم
ردما اتوني زبر
الحديد حتى اذا ساوى بين الصدفين قال
نفخوه حتى اذا جعله نارا قال ات
افرغ عليه
قطرا فما اسطاعوا ان يظهروه وما استطاعوا
له
نقبا قال هذا رحمه من
ربي فاذا
جاء وعد ربي جعله
دكا وكان وعد ربي حقا
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وتركنا بعضهم يومئذ يموج في بعض ونفخ
في الصور فجمعناهم جمعا وعرضنا
جهنم ي يومئذ للكافرين
عرضا الذين كانت اعينهم في
غطاء عن ذكري وكانوا لا يستطيعون
سمعا افحسب الذين كفروا ان يتخذوا عبادي
من دوني
اولياء
انا اعتدنا جهن انم للكافرين
نزلا قل هل ننبئكم
بالاخسرين
اعمالا الذين ضل سعيهم في الحياه الدنيا
وهم يحسبون انهم يحسنون
صنعا
اولئك الذين كفروا بايات ربهم
ولقائه فحبطت
اعمالهم فحبطت
اعمالهم فلا نقيم لهم يوم القيامه
وزنا ذلك
جزاؤهم
جهنم بما كفروا واتخذوا
اياتي واتخذوا اياتي ورسلي
هزوا ان الذين امنوا وعملوا الص حات كانت
لهم جنات الفردوس
نزلا خالدين فيها لا يبغون عنها
حولا قل لو كان البحر مدادا لكلمات ربي
لنفد
البحر لنفد البحر قبل ان تنفد كلمات
ربي ولو جئنا بمثل له
مددا قل
انما انا
بشر مثلكم يوحى
الي يوحى الي
انما الهكم اله
واحد فمن كان يرجو لقاء ربه فليعمل عملا
صالحا
يعمل
عملا
صالحا ولا يشرك بعباده ربه
احدا الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر سميع سم الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
ا
السلام ouate
[Silence]
‏so we kindly ask you just please don't
touch switches see kids
touching
second
soest
when there was ach of kids in the back
fighting run around and there severals
who walked by and have a video this can
come me after and nobody st
[Silence]
استقيموا اعتدلوا
استو ان شاء الله تلاوه سجده ركعه ان شاء
الله
تلاه ان شاء
الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
كاف ه يا
عين ص
ذكر رحمه ربك عبده
زكريا اذ نادى ربه نداء
نداء
خفيا قال رب اني وهن العظم مني واشتعل
الراس
شيبا واشتعل الراس شيبا ولم اكن
بدعائك رب شقيا
واني خفت الموالي من ورائي وكانت امراتي
عاقرا فهب لي من لدنك
وليا يرثني ويرث من ال يعقوب واجعله ربي
رضيا يا زكريا انا نبشرك بغلام اسمه
يحيى لم نجعل له من قبل
سميا قال رب انا يكون لي غلام وقد بلغني
الكبر وكانت امراتي
عاقرا قال كذلك قال ربك هو علي هين وقد
خلقتك من قبل ولم تك شيئا قال رب اجعل لي
ايه قال ايتك الا تكلم الناس ثلاث ليال
سويا فخرج على قومه من المحراب
فاوحى اليهم ان سبحوا بكره
وعشيا يا يحيى خذ الكتاب بقوه
واتيناه الحكم
صبيا
وحنانا من لدنا وزكاه و كان
رضيا وكان
تقيا
وبرا بوالديه ولم يكن جبارا
شقيا ولم يكن جبارا
عصيا وسلام عليه يوم ولد ويوم يموت ويوم
يبعث
حيا واذكر في الكتاب مريم اذ انتبذت من
اهلها مكانا
قصيا واذكر في الكتاب مريم اذ انتبذت من
شرقيا فاتخذت من دونهم حجابا فارسلنا
اليها روحنا فتمثل لها فتمثل لها بشرا
سويا قالت اني اعوذ بالرحمن منك ان كنت
تقيا قال
انما انا بشر قال
انما قال انما انا رسول ربك لاهب لك غلاما
زكيا قالت
انا يكون لي غلام ولم يمسسني بشر
ولم يمسسني بشر ولم اك
بغيا قال كذلك قال كذلك قال ربك هو علي
هين
ولنجعله ايه للناس
ورحمه
منا وكان امرا
مقضيا فحملته فانتبذت به مكانا
قصيا
فاجاءها المخاض الى جذع نخله قالت يا
ليتني مت قبل هذا وكنت نسيا
منسيا فناداها من تحتها الا
تحزني الا تحزني قد جعل ربك تحتك سري
وهزي اليك بجذع النخله تساقط عليك رطبا
جنيا فكلي واشربي وقري عيناه
فاما
ترين من البشر احدا
فقولي فقولي اني نذرت للرحمن صوما فلن
اكلم اليوم
سيا فاتت به قومها
تحمله قالوا يا مريم لقد جئت شيئا
فريا يا اخت هارون ما كان ابوك امرا سوء
وما كانت امك
بغيا فاشارت
اليه قالوا كيف كلم من كان في المهد
صبيا قال اني عبد الله اتاني
الكتاب اتاني الكتاب واجعلني
نبيا وجعلني مباركا اينما كنت واوصاني
بالصلاه والزكاه ما دمت حيا وبرا
بوالدتي ولم اكن جبارا
شقيا ولم يجعلني جبارا
شقيا والسلام علي يوم ولدت ويوم اموت ويوم
ابعث
حيا الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ذلك عيسى ابن مريم قول الحق الذي فيه
يمترون ما كان لله ان يتخذ من ولد سبحان
سبحانه اذا قضى امرا فانما يقول له كن
فيكون وان الله ربي وربكم فاعبدوه هذا
صراط
مستقيم فاختلف الاحزاب من بينهم فويل
للذين كفروا من مشهد يوم عظيم اسمع بهم
وابصر يوم
ياتوننا لكن الظالمون اليوم في
ضلال مبين
وانذرهم يوم الحسره اذ قضي الامر وهم في
غفله وهم في غفله وهم لا
يؤمنون انا نحن نرث الارض ومن عليها
والينا يرجعون واذكر في الكتاب ابرا
ابراهيم انه كان صديقا
نبيا اذ قال لابيه يا ابت لم تعبد ما لا
يسمع ولا يبصر ولا يغني عنك
شيئا يا ابت اني قد
جاءني من العلم ما لم ياتك فاتبعني
فاتبعني اهدك صراطا سويا
يا ابت لا تعبد الشيطان ان الشيطان
للانسان
عصيا يا ابت لا تعبد الشيطان ان الشيطان
كان للرحمن
عصيا يا ابت اني اخاف ان يمسك عذاب من
الرحمن فتكون للشيطان
وليا قال راغب انت عن الهتي يا ابراهيم لئ
لم
تنته لارجمنك
واهجرني
مليا قال سلام عليك ساستغفر لك ربي
انه كان بي
حفيا
واعتزلكم وما تدعون من دون الله
الله وادعوا ربي عسى الا اكون بدعاء ربي
شقيا فلما اعتزلهم وما يعبدون من دون الله
وهبنا
له وهبنا له اسحاق ويعقوب وكلا جعلنا نبيا
ووهبنا له